avec pour créer la surprise l'équipe 2
de la commune qui joue en noir s'est
imposé sur la pelouse de verneuil lors
de la 19e journée de deuxième division
de district après avoir mené 2 à 0 les
visiteurs se font rejoindre à deux
partout sur ce penalty les ardres et
courtois profiteront des espaces en fin
de match pour marquer trois buts score
final 5 à 2 les gars ont respecté les
consignes ce n'était pas un match facile
on s'attendait on savait qu'on allait
avoir une opposition difficile face à
verneuil qui jouait le haut du tableau
mais dans l'ensemble on voit là les gars
ont sorti le match qu'il fallait quand
il fallait
on a manqué un peu de réalisme après ils
ont su nous contrer ils ont été
efficaces
du coup mené 2-0 à la mi-temps donc
difficile mais voilà on a essayé de
pousser ça n'a pas marché
après ce match vernet pointe à la
troisième place du classement à deux
journées de la fin du championnat
son côté hardricourt en difficulté
depuis le début de la saison respire
l'équipe est désormais 9e et s'éloigne
de la zone de relégation
le maintien normalement il assure
aujourd'hui mais bon il nous reste
encore deux matches à jouer on va les
jouer à fond pour gagner une ou deux
places encore sur des matches comme ça
voilà ça fait plaisir et on pense qu'on
va pouvoir ainsi pas prochain match pour
les deux équipes le dimanche 19 mai vers
nice se déplacera sur le terrain de vale
78 et hardricourt recevra sur sa pelouse
le club de belgique